for those who don't remember honey is  frozen's wife and she's never seen in  the first film that she has definitely  heard we thought that it might be fun if  we introduced a person that you learn  over the course of the scene is honey  you see someone reacting to something  outside and the first thing that she  does is she presses a remote and the  wall turns around and everyone will go  oh this is frozen's apartment that must  be honey but we felt like we a stayed  away from the big action scene too long  and that we were killing the momentum  that we were gaining by having this big  action scene and B we also ultimately  decided the off-camera nests of it is  part of the joke and then honey can be  kind of anyone you imagine her to be I'm  not playing with you it was filthy  [Music]